le nouveau service peps accessible à
tous a pour but de permettre aux
concitoyens d'avoir un accès direct aux
procédures administratives comme les
demandes de raccordement de sa maison à
l'assainissement collectif ou encore
l'obtention d'une attestation en vue
d'une vente immobilière
le peps portail espace public service va
permettre aux usagers du territoire
d'avoir leurs démarches facilitées
alors on va l'étendre bien sûr à la
totalité des services mais on a commencé
dans un premier temps par tout ce qui
est concerne les réseaux et réseaux
assainissement et éclairage public
le portail numérique peps s'installe
dans une logique de dématérialisation
des procédures administratives
ça s'inscrit dans le côté innovant de 50
ans des vinyles je rappelle 50 elle une
terre d'innovation mais nous continuons
cette innovation bien sûr nous avions
d'être site internet que tout le monde
connait nous avions aussi en ligne les
spectacles et billetterie en ligne aussi
tout ce qui concerne les médiathèques
les locations par exemple pour les
étudiants est bien là nous continuons à
développer notre savoir faire technique
pour toucher le maximum de personnes et
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines ne compte pas s'arrêter là le
site devrait dans un avenir proche
donner des infos sur la collecte des
ordures ménagères ou encore les travaux
sur la voirie